hello I'm actually a rubios and this
quite loud and a JavaScript developer
portrayed so CSS is kind of like a
necessity for me and so this talk is had
a sneak JavaScript into a CSS comp I'm
going if you're walking tour of how
folks USS works and I'm going to teach
you how I can into how integrated it to
an e-commerce platform to convert that
platform from English to Arabic so I try
to hold on to things and I was trying to
make it fail because I wanted this to be
a story of agony because they're way
more fun to watch I find tragedies the
best for this story okay so about me I
do a mean Ron Swanson impression my name
is Lachlan priest I go by at LC priests
pretty much everywhere there are two
Lachlan fries on this planet one's a 16
year 16 Australian and he stole my
twitter handle he followed Justin Bieber
and then stopped using Twitter so I'm
just gonna give it to him and you won
this one dick yeah so most the time if
I'm working on Ruby on Rails and images
so I always here so is Ruby Jade yet is
in bj's dead yet I'm like not just go
back to my work now so this is what I
work on a specially closed source but I
try and contribute one thing a week back
to open source generally in systems or
integrations that I'm working with like
closely not really sure why Thomas let
me speak to the CSS comp but let's go so
I went for trade gecko that's this group
up front they're my co-workers and I
Boston to laugh for me so just use their
cue um so this little guy he's moco I
have stickers if you want some stickers
he was invented by our design team and
he is the embodiment of our company
thats is a James Bond theme I think
shakin what's dead my official job title
is the most huggable engineer okay so
post ESS uh it is who knows it sounded
cool and I wanted to remove sass from a
JavaScript object we're working on
because we have one main API and I was
building an e-commerce platform that use
that API but didn't need to have any
back in
services so I didn't want a lib SAS
dependency so I just had to use post CSS
so what is it I'm no idea well I had no
idea whenever I do a blog or a talk I
like to pick something I've never
touched before and learn about it so
that's what I did how do you learn about
things go to github great this tells me
nothing it is a tool for transforming
styles with jes plugins that means
nothing to me okay but if you look down
further it's talking about how post CSS
passes CSS and lets you do other things
so it does nothing by itself but with
other things you can do magic okay so
when I started this this talk I had a
hypothesis that I would fail at this and
would be a great story of me failing
something anyway and the point I wanted
to make was that it's more important to
do your job than to play with new
technologies being with ruby on rails in
in bjs everyone asked me why we haven't
moved to go or some new fancy language
that is great we didn't move because
there's a lot of effort and I want to do
features so now with Paula CSS I wanted
to find out what I can use it for okay
so I'll take an input file this is some
CSS as you can see and store / CSS and
run it I had to include this plug-in on
the far right which I wrote because you
can't even run / CSS without a plugin it
does nothing don't worry this is the
output it's exactly the same what does
Posey assistive it's not a preprocessor
the main thing you hear when you talk
about posea says is that it's not sass
it's not less it doesn't do any of those
things but it can it's just a passer and
it passes your CSS into a series of
notes so the nodes go like this there's
a root node that is your entire fifth
his file there are rules those are divs
whatever all the elements classes and
ID's there are declarations which are
like color and this color is really
important it is gecko green like the
t-shirts and just a nice font and then
there are comments so you can track all
of those things using Pro CSS and then
perform operations on those things post
CSS provides a nice little API to that
is provided to all plugin
we were past an object called container
and that can that object has a variety
of functions the functions are walk
declarations walk rules and what
comments they're essentially a for each
I don't know why they call it that for
those specific things now if we go back
to those things a declaration is a CSS
property a rule is a different class and
comment is a comment obviously so the
API comes with little plugins and
because it's just an API and does
nothing the community provided
everything else here's a list of some of
the plugins there's like 200 of them so
I'll go over the first bit again i think
i just talked about this the main point
is that it's not a preprocessor it's not
really anything but there is a
preprocessor processor plugin so pre CSS
provides you everything that SAS
provides you but with just a JavaScript
so in my day job I have this this is an
e-commerce platform it has like 10
different pages it's very small very
easy to use and it's got demo data about
Willy Wonka I don't know why it's always
been in our production that's always
going to stay so I want to replace ass
with row CSS so i did that i installed
post ESS apparently the normal library
is broken so there's a fixed one and
then i installed pre CSS which is the
SAS drop-in replacement nothing changed
again so at this point I kind of had
like a draft email to Thomas being like
this isn't working I was trying to be
funny nothing's breaking it just works I
had away how do I make this story about
posties his failing means sticking with
the status quo work so i decided to try
and break it it's pretty hard actually
so what do I do now let's translate the
website so anyone that works with me
knows that my main contributor can check
our contribution to github is in all the
qas I'll call out all of the files you
haven't translated and just what i 18 n
or internationalisation like hundreds of
times everywhere all the time it's the
most annoying thing but it helps so even
with my admittedly very aggressive
stance
I've never actually translated a project
I've just made it possible so how was /
CSS useful here it's not really so and
here comes ma this is my he's my co
worker that works on slack by the way
you can use gifts and it's amazing what
happens okay so mo and I we run a meetup
called Ruby tea party where we teach you
what Ruby because there aren't enough in
the community and I love Ruby this is
really important to me because I taught
myself the code and the community really
helped me with that so I wanted to give
back so Mohamed and I always talk about
startups on what we could do and how
sorry Mohammed's from Syria speaks
Arabic and we're discussing how no one
really caters towards the Arabic market
so wouldn't it be cool if we could build
a project that works for them so first
of all I wanted to try it in our own
projects because I don't really have any
side projects worth marketing right now
or ever i don't know i'm not very busy
so if you want to come to the tea party
by the way it's every thursday come talk
to me we have great offices in this free
food so the way we can work with arabic
is that there are two things yet to do
one is translate the project and the
second has changed at X direction and
even the flow of the app so there is a
plugin for Posey SS surprise that does
this this is an example of github if you
reverse it they've still got an English
I don't know why but this is the point
this is mohammed a different mohammed
that I reached out to an almost offered
a job too but he was in Jordan and
didn't leave any you need to make sure
that your site not just is in Arabic but
feels native to an Arabic speaker so the
way this plugin works is that it takes
your CSS this is the top and the bottom
and all it really does is it finds all
lefts and rights and equivalent things
and switches them so if you run the plug
in your position relative left hand
picks becomes right Tim picks and it
just works because every time you
reference aside like float left position
left texture issue a direction left to
right all year to do is reverse it and
then suddenly it works because the
browser was just this way there's no up
and down there's no rotation great
obviously before you can translate so
I'm going to slow down going for
just obviously before you can translate
is a bunch of manual work like putting
all your strings in your app into one
file so this is all of the texts i think
it's another like 500 lines in that
e-commerce store it's only like nine
hundred words and i had to get it
translated obviously i could have asked
mohammed but he's got stuff to do so i
found a service the same way that i
always find something new if I want to
learn a new technology you'll see how
best practices it is I go check out
discourse discourse is a images and
rails app it's much bigger than ours in
its open source so it's always a good
spot to work on like scaling problems or
learn new things so the way they
translate it I think it's in like 60
languages now the way they translated it
is with this project called transifex
you just throw your strings in there and
you can translate it as a group or you
can pay someone I obviously didn't have
a group so I found someone to pay and it
was like 130 dollars the translate to
Arabic incredibly cheap didn't wanna pay
myself so I convinced my boss but so
here are the numbers to commit your bust
by the way there are 19 countries that
speak Arabic natively 280 million eight
is needed Arabic speakers five percent
of our customers are from arabic arabic
countries and for naps in the world
speaks over in Italy natively so why are
these customers using our product at
that ratio which is higher than the
standard if there is something available
for the Arab market turns out there
isn't if you look so my company does
inventory management software if you
look up English inventory management
software you get seven million results
in English half million in Arabic and if
you actually use average tank text you
get even less so 123 dollars and 36
hours later my site was in Arabic super
easy there we go whoops 12 mini now it's
an Arabic obviously I didn't translate
the dynamic data I probably could have
given you example data for that but all
of the layout is and it looks pretty
nice actually so this is where
right-to-left CSS comes in I had to
reverse the UI direction in order to you
know make it more comfortable for Arabic
speakers so rad clear CSS comes along
runs it over my files and it's not
perfect
in fact it breaks quite a lot in random
places but that's actually a case of
first of type last child etc when you're
trying to do border radiuses and a few
other things and it just doesn't work
perfectly but a little bit of hand with
your magic layer and it looks great so
everything is aligned I may have just
used developer tools for this but so
telia / CSS does nothing but it provides
an API for us to do everything like if
we go back to those previous slides I'm
not going to jump in so it's like 30
back there are approximately 200
different plugins available ones that do
like color blindness to usability
obviously i think is a translation one
minification CSS next is this for BAM
linting that's really important five
teams are trying to move to bem just a
million of them one of them CSS format
that all is great I ran at once and I
think in committed four thousand lines
of CSS to github because it tied
everything up great so Perseus does
nothing it's just an API but it allows
for a awesome ecosystem to form and one
of the things I love about it is it
allows people to stop arguing about
Seth's like capabilities because they
don't want Ruby could dependencies in
the jas projects I love sass it's great
I want to stick with it as long as
possible but if I can get all of the
functionality SS without using Ruby or
lips s or whatever it's great I would
love to do that because in bridge is
great and I never want to touch Ruby
when I'm touching Ember anyway ok so I
think I've gone a little bit too fast
that was my second to last slides I
don't know why this video came out but
it came with so many cool gifts this guy
is amazing sidenote internationalisation
gets really addictive here it is in
Spanish um that took me another 36 hours
at one hundred twenty dollars as you can
see it's super easy let's go more into
my CSS I can do this for hours so the
community is super weird one of the
things that I as a new zealand I just
like about si si
that's in American English someone fixed
that you can now write your CSS as if
you're British what the you with
transparency with sintel as its to be
spelled and it just translates just
compile sorry to the right version our
very own Sebastian deckers who's
actually teaching across the road he put
this one which is amazing so you can use
nonsense units in his fiercest and it
just works that joke there is 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea so my contribution
was a post English post ESS English
style sheets I had to get a co-worker to
check this to make sure I wasn't insane
Thank You jing-mei um it was really hard
to find a lot of things I ended up just
doing colors this entire thing was built
in like twelve lines of JavaScript so
that's just doing the warp declarations
and then you can just go over each them
and it just gripped um I did the ice
kacang is my favorite it does the the
gradient and it's beautiful I don't I
guess foreigners wouldn't understand
that one but anyway that's great man I'm
way and time sorry I shoulda spoke and
slow okay so you want to learn more
check out discourse discourse is an
awesome resource for learning rails
umber scaling just anything transifex
was the translation software that took
me maybe 20 minutes to master the U is
not amazing but they're getting there
obviously pro CSS is available and if
you didn't actually listen to me there's
another video of a guy who wrote OH CSS
Heaney's available to this is pushing
he's a ginger with a mustache like me um
I couldn't find a top hat in the monocle
but I tried pretty hard sorry I went
away under time doing any questions
excuse gone when you were playing around
with post CSS apart from dodgy
translations and things like that did
you find any plugins they're quite
useful or do you not really use it at
the moment I actually I dropped it into
I'm a nap and replace s like it was I
did everything I needed to do I was just
surprised it work so easily like I
wanted to be like its Tara
don't use it but it just worked
perfectly so at the moment I'm using CSS
and nano which is a mentor fire i'm
using scissors next so i can try and
drop variables and use the standard one
that's coming out with CSS for either of
them I don't think this is this for
think it's called CSS next and we're
also using pre CSS to replace s
obviously and i'm probably going to put
in beam lint in the future because
brooke my main front end co-worker is
trying to get us a switch it works
really well i also i wanted to do one
for color blindness because our company
uses way too many like greys and I want
to like demonstrate that to out like
exec team yeah I was just wondering like
you were saying pre CSS what's very well
if you convert from SAS to Paul CSS I
was just wondering if you use like
multiple libraries or obsess mix-ins was
it like things up so pre CSS is a
set of smaller / CSS libraries that give
you all of those functionalities are
posted says at rules which is the main
sets mix in tool and then post ESS
nested and process variable so
appreciate this is actually just a
package of plugins so it gives you all
of the different things that sass users
and I think they maintain it to be
that's compatible I don't know there's a
less one but don't use less just on